[Musique]
avec le soutien financier du Fonds
citoyen franco-allemand bonsoir radio
sensation et sur TV 78 sous sommes à HF
and Burke pour un numéro spécial
enregistré en Bavière en Allemagne et
réalisé avec le soutien du fond citoyen
franco-allemand on parlera notamment
Europe droit LGBT environnement
éducation et musique mais pour commencer
j'ai rendez-vous avec Jurgen erzing
c'est
[Musique]
une ville de 70 000 habitants when you
lorsque l'on visite la ville on peut
voir ce très beau château juste à côté
du mail il représente la ville est-ce
que vous pouvez nous présenter à shaf
and gold
est une ville de 72000 habitants nous
avons un fleuve le Maine le château de
Johannesburg et d'autres attractions
touristiques
la région est très marquée par
l'industrialisation les chariots
élévateurs de l'entreprise Linda utilisé
dans toute l'Europe et à travers le
monde entier sont fabriqués ici nous
avons environ 65 000 emplois ici à
Chaffin de Bourg sinns United depuis
1975 votre ville est jumelée avec
Saint-Germain-en-Laye comment ce
jumelage s'est-il fait
c'était une initiative conjointe de
l'État fédéral et de la région car après
les nombreuses guerres entre la France
et l'Allemagne on a voulu promouvoir
l'amitié entre les deux peuples c'est
comme ça que nous avons été mis en
contact avec Saint-Germain-en-Laye
que pensez-vous de Saint-Germain-en-Laye
nous avons beaucoup de points communs
par exemple le Château Le fleuve la
taille de la ville et nous sommes unis
par un lien très chaleureux qui s'est
construit au fil des années
on est allé en France mais pas à Paris
quelque part sur la côte c'était la
première fois et pour nous en tant
qu'enfant c'était tout à fait normal et
très chouette
est-ce que ces activités liées aux
jumelage vous ont permis de changer le
regard que vous aviez sur ce pays
on retourne à Saint-Germain au mois de
décembre enfin on se retrouve en
personne pour la première fois après la
pandémie même si bien sûr nous nous
sommes régulièrement retrouvés en ligne
aussi pour fêter l'existence du
partenariat nous restons en contact nous
échangeons beaucoup c'est surtout le
lien entre les associations et les
pompiers volontaires qui fait vivre le
partenariat
avec Perse en Écosse depuis 1956 et
depuis 1996 avec la ville de mitscoq en
Hongrie est-ce qu'il y a des différences
avec le jumelage avec
Saint-Germain-en-Laye training with
Saint-Germain-en-Laye
chaque ville assez spécificités chaque
ville et chaque nationalité on leur
propre histoire mais en ce qui concerne
le jumelage c'est un lien d'amitié qui
nous unit il n'y a pas de différence
entre le partenariat avec Saint-Germain
avec Perth en école ou missclock en
Hongrie ce qui nous anime c'est l'idée
de l'amitié au-delà des frontières la
paix la joie et l'amitié c'est ça qui
nous tient à cœur qui nous motive et ça
fonctionne très bien
merci beaucoup Ivan
je rappelle que vous êtes Le Maire
d'achat finborg
zone Europe
avec le soutien financier du Fonds
citoyen franco-allemand
[Musique]
zone Europe
nous voilà installé dans le studio de
radio klanbred la radio jeunesse d'achat
Fender avec nos sens à Reporters Théo
gagnage et Loris Simonet étudiant en
journalisme à Hegi Montpellier nous
avons voulu savoir quelle image les
Allemands avaient des Français écouter
sur les Français sont qu'il serait
homophobes qu'il serait raciste et
qu'ils auront une haine envers les
Allemands ou envers d'autres gens
étrangers
les Français comme je les connais sont
ouverts gentillés ouais il savoure la
vie quoi
les Français ont de bons goûts j'entends
souvent dire qu'il n'aime pas parler
l'anglais et l'allemand ils aiment
parler dans leur propre langue
je pense que la France est un bon pays à
visiter c'est un endroit cool concernant
les clichés je n'ai jamais rencontré de
français donc je n'ai pas vraiment
d'opinion sur la question
en France il y a de très beaux paysages
et de superbes villes j'ai été à
Biarritz c'est super bien quand j'y suis
allé Paris est jolie tout comme Nice les
gens sont gentils et on y mange très
bien bref un beau pays
la France est un super pays et surtout
le sud
concernant les clichés les Français ont
une culture de la grève qu'on ne
retrouve nulle part ailleurs et je
trouve ça bien dans une démocratie c'est
un partenaire important dans l'Union
européenne pour faire face aux grandes
puissances étrangères
les Français sont des personnes qui ne
peuvent être appréciées autant que
toutes les personnes du monde entier
je ne fais pas de différence entre les
nations je ne suis pas ancienne mais je
ne trouve pas vraiment de différence
parce que je pense que nous sommes tous
des frères et des soeurs c'est de cette
manière que nous devrions nous comporter
sur ça j'aime beaucoup les Français
comme tout le monde
des avis très variés peut-être
influencés par les films ou bien par
l'école via l'apprentissage du français
l'Allemagne aussi étonnant que cela
puisse paraître et le cinquième pays le
plus francophone du monde avec Théo 12,2
millions de locuteurs alors en effet
Corentin je suis retourné à l'école pour
assister à un cours et voir quelques
méthodes utilisées pour enseigner notre
langue on écoute d'ailleurs elle que
Schmitt professeur de français au
cranbert gymnasium alors normalement on
a un programme qui est soutenu par les
manuels qu'on utilise dans le cours mais
en plus on essaie de créer des contacts
personnels parce que c'est une grande
motivation pour les élèves
soit par un échange avec notre lycée
jumelé avec nous sans jamais en Lay ou
avec des actions différentes aller au
cinéma ou invité à Radio d'autres
invités ou aussi des actions locales
faire la cuisine ensemble c'est à dire
la motivation est vraiment importante
est-ce que globalement la matière
française est aimée par les jeunes
allemands ou est-ce qu'ils ont un autre
avis dessus alors c'est difficile à dire
pour le gros moi je dirais pour un autre
école il y a plusieurs filières à notre
école
la filière avec les langues on aime
beaucoup il a toujours un groupe qui est
très motivé qui passe le pas qui va à
l'étranger même après le bac et il y a
aussi un groupe qui dit bon je n'aime
pas trop mais on a aussi des
alternatives donc on peut choisir le
français donc pour nous les profs c'est
aussi
oui toujours un défi de motiver pendant
les élections de de pour que les élèves
se disent pour le français parce que la
concurrence de l'espagnol et l'anglais
c'est forte bien sûr
et finalement est-ce que après tout ce
parcours scolaire il y a beaucoup
d'Allemands qui deviennent bilingues
français allemand est-ce que c'est une
langue un petit peu trop compliquée oui
ça reste plus compliqué que que
l'anglais mais il y a toujours quelque
chose moi aussi j'ai déjà des élèves qui
sont devenus prof ou qui aiment beaucoup
la France qui vont ou à l'étranger après
le bac ça arrive souvent mais bien sûr
c'est plus facile d'apprendre l'anglais
ou l'espagnol pour les élèves et le
français peut parfois être un atout pour
partir à l'étranger car l'Union
européenne c'est aussi les échanges
culturels avec notamment le programme
Erasmus depuis 35 ans c'est 12 millions
d'Européens qui en ont profité dont un
million d'Allemands mais il existe aussi
d'autres programmes on écoute Marisa
Gilles elle est coordinatrice pour les
volontaires au bureau européen d'achat
fenburg
quelles sont les missions de Europa
office notre mission est d'envoyer des
jeunes dans différents pays européens
ainsi que dans les pays environnants
comme les Balkans et l'Afrique du Nord
nous ouvrons aussi pour qu'ils profitent
de l'expérience en rencontrant de
nouvelles personnes et qu'ils deviennent
des citoyens ouverts
d'esprites dans des défis sociaux ou en
faveur de l'environnement donc leur
projet peuvent être un caractère social
sportif environnemental ou même
culturels comme cela serait le cas pour
une radio par exemple
comment préparez-vous les personnes
avant de partir d'Allemagne
d'abord nous les rencontrons en
visioconférence ou en présentiel ensuite
nous leur donnons toutes les
informations dont ils ont besoin et
répondons à toutes leurs questions
parfois ils rencontrent d'autres
bénévoles avant de partir et établissent
ainsi un contact avec de nouvelles
personnes
les Allemands aiment-ils voyager
oui les Allemands adorent voyager et je
crois que leur destination préférée sont
les pays européens
la France c'est un pays attractif oui
sans aucun doute je suppose que c'est
parce que nous entretenons une longue
amitié il y a eu beaucoup de problèmes
par le passé mais maintenant il s'agit
d'une longue relation et beaucoup
d'Allemands le savent une autre raison
évidemment et que vous êtes nos voisins
et il est toujours important d'avoir une
bonne relation avec ses voisins quels
sont les autres pays que les Allemands
choisissent beaucoup d'allemand aiment
aller en Espagne ou en Italie l'Irlande
également est un pays apprécié par les
Allemands je pense aussi que si la
Grande-Bretagne était toujours dans
l'Union européenne ils aimeraient se
rendre là-bas malheureusement le brexit
est passé par là on va parler à présent
des droits LGBT en Allemagne depuis le
1er octobre 2017 le mariage homosexuel
et légal oui en effet j'ai rencontré
Andreas rodic de l'association Rainbow
AB il revient d'ailleurs sur
l'amélioration des droits LGBT ici en
Allemagne
[Musique]
depuis 2017 le mariage pour tous existe
en Allemagne
concernant les personnes transexuelles
il existe une loi depuis 1981 mais elle
est loin d'être parfaite et nécessite
toujours des améliorations cela fait
d'ailleurs partie des problèmes
politiques débattus en ce moment en
Allemagne nous espérons que cela amènera
à des améliorations dans les prochaines
années pour la partie sexuelle je pense
qu'on a atteint une sorte d'égalité mais
uniquement d'un point de vue légal et
non pas dans la société
en 2013 pourquoi avez-vous décidé de
créer l'association il y avait-il à ce
moment-là beaucoup d'agressions
homophobes
la décision a été prise pour donner
suite à la restructuration d'un groupe
déjà créé nous nous sommes alors fixés
de nouveaux objectifs
nous souhaitons agir davantage au niveau
politique depuis nous restons encore une
association d'actions très locales
contrairement à l'association originale
notre activité se limite à acheter une
bourre mais pour répondre à la question
des agressions non il n'y avait pas
beaucoup d'agressions homophobes à
schaffenburg bien entendu il y a
toujours des imbéciles comme partout
mais cela ne représente pas un véritable
problème ici
aujourd'hui en Allemagne la situation
c'était l'améliorée
c'est difficile à dire parce que nous ne
voyons que le côté local mon sentiment
général cependant et que oui la
situation s'est améliorée
les jeunes sont beaucoup plus éduqués
aujourd'hui et donc plus tolérant
qu'avant c'est d'ailleurs un des points
sur lesquels nous travaillons avec
l'association
que pensez-vous qu'il est nécessaire de
faire pour améliorer la situation des
LGBTQ ici en Allemagne
je crois que c'est très important
d'éduquer les gens sur les droits des
personnes LGBTQ sur leurs problèmes mais
aussi sur l'histoire de ce mouvement que
veut dire être une personne cuir c'est
essentiel de le savoir pour améliorer
tant la tolérance que l'acceptation
en ce qui concerne l'Allemagne d'un
point de vue global cela passerait par
la création d'une loi contre la
discrimination comme c'est déjà le cas
dans d'autres pays comme le Portugal par
exemple nous avons peut-être besoin nous
aussi d'une telle législation
et finalement comment votre association
Rainbow AB aide les personnes LGBTQ ici
à schaffenburg nous organisons des
ateliers dans les écoles pour
sensibiliser les élèves et pour leur
donner une idée de comment c'est d'être
une personne cuir
nous organisons également une Gay Pride
ici à schaffenburg une fois par an
et puis nous offrons à tous les jeunes
et personnes cuir un espace de sécurité
pour qu'il soit eux-mêmes et qu'il n'est
pas à craindre le jugement des autres
l'environnement c'est l'une des
préoccupations majeures des jeunes et
les Allemands ni échappent vous avez pu
rencontrer une jeune Allemande engagée
en faveur du climat oui c'est ça j'ai pu
échanger avec Eden de Friday forfaiture
mouvement créé par la Suédoise Greta
Thunberg elle nous explique comment
l'antenne d'achat finburg a vu le jour
je crois que notre groupe a été créé il
y a trois ans
Friday for future est une organisation
plutôt importante ici en Allemagne avec
plusieurs groupes locaux implantés
partout dans le pays
comme achat fait une bourre n'est pas
une petite ville je pense que la
population est d'environ 80000 personnes
il nous a semblé logique de créer notre
propre groupe quand nous manifestons
pendant le temps scolaire il est plus
simple d'organiser nos manifestations
ici cela nous évite un trajet d'une
heure pour aller à Francfort voilà en
résumé sur la faisait sens pour nous et
nous avons donc juste décidé de créer un
groupe ici à shuff and Burg est-ce que
les gens sont respectueux de
l'environnement
je pense que c'est le cas nous avons
quelques personnes de droite qui sont
vraiment énervées contre nous car nous
manifestons environ deux fois par an
mais je crois qu'à ça fait une bourre
l'environnement est une vraie
préoccupation et nous en prononçons
beaucoup de personnes se déplacent à
vélo et je sais que les autorités
locales font aussi tout leur possible
pour rendre les transports publics plus
abordables les samedis par exemple tous
les transports en commun sont gratuits
dans toute la ville on peut donc dire
que nous faisons tout notre possible
localement même si il est compliqué de
mettre en place des actions positives
pour l'environnement quand les hommes
politiques nationaux ne nous laisse pas
le faire
quels sont les moyens mis en oeuvre pour
rendre les gens plus respectueux de
l'environnement
nous essayons de sensibiliser le public
à l'environnement en manifestant bien
entendu je crois que notre dernière
manifestation remonte à septembre cela
fait donc un moment maintenant que nous
n'avons rien organisé mais nous sommes
conscients que nous devons parler aux
citoyens de notre ville aux autorités
locales nous essayons toujours de
communiquer avec toutes ces personnes je
me souviens qu'avant les élections à
schaffenburg ont passé nous avons
organisé un rassemblement vraiment
important avant lequel nous avions
rencontré tous les hommes politiques qui
font actuellement partie du parlement
allemand nous avons discuté avec eux
pour nous assurer qu'il savait que notre
ville celle qui sont proposer représenté
et sensibiliser à la question
environnementale
qu'elle fait tout son possible pour
cette cause
depuis la création de l'association en
2018 est-ce que vous trouvez que la
mentalité des gens ici a changé je pense
profondément nous pouvons le constater
dans notre ville mais aussi au niveau
global il est clair qu'ici les gens ont
changé leur vision du climat car ils
sont plus sensibilisés ils utilisent
moins leur voiture ils essayent de
privilégier les transports en commun
c'est cela qui a changé à mon avis au
niveau local et à un niveau plus général
je pense que l'environnement est devenu
un vrai sujet dans le cadre des
politiques internationales il existe
désormais plusieurs rendez-vous par an
durant lesquels les hommes politiques du
monde entier se réunissent pour discuter
de comment améliorer la question du
climat il y a également la manière avec
laquelle on essaie de changer nos
pratiques énergétiques et ce genre de
choses qui démontre qu'il est clair que
les mentalités ont changé je suis très
fier de cela parce que je peux voir que
nous en tant que jeune nous à avoir un
impact majeur sur la politique
internationale et cela est chouette
avoir
la musique allemande n'est pas très
connue en France mis à part Ramstein ou
encore Tokyo hôtel Loris vous avez
profité de votre séjour à hfburg ici
pour rencontrer une artiste locale oui
c'est ça j'ai rencontré Sofia elle-même
une jeune chanteuse de 23 ans qui baigne
dans la musique depuis le plus jeune âge
j'ai commencé à écrire des chansons
quand j'étais assez jeune comme beaucoup
d'enfants j'ai appris d'abord à jouer de
la guitare et du piano et j'ai fait
partie aussi de l'orchestre de l'école
mais je suis allé plus loin ensuite en
écrivant mes propres chansons les
premières d'entre elles ont été faites
pour le mariage de ma sœur ce sont
d'ailleurs ces chansons qu'on a
enregistré pour mon premier album
memories en 2013 c'était alors mon début
dans le monde de la musique et je ne me
suis pas arrêté depuis
Sofia comment pourrais-tu nous décrire
ton univers musical
je pense que j'ai mon propre univers et
ma manière de comprendre le monde ma
musique parle beaucoup d'amour je crois
que vivre et aimer c'est rechercher
l'équilibre parmi nos différentes phases
nous traversons tous des étapes dans la
vie et la musique est un moyen
extraordinaire de communiquer et d'en
parler vous savez la vie n'est pas
simple et c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous avons tant d'émotion à partager et
que nous sommes obligés de faire quelque
chose avec elle et il me semble que la
musique est la meilleure manière de
communiquer sur celle-ci nous ne parlons
pas tous la même langue je ne parle pas
français par exemple mais quand j'écoute
de la musique française je peux toujours
comprendre ce qu'elle veut dire car cela
reste de la musique c'est cela que
j'adore avec la musique et c'est ce que
j'espère faire ressentir avec ma musique
également
et as-tu déjà été inspiré par la musique
française
j'ai grandi dans une famille qui aimait
vraiment la musique elle était partout
et à tout moment ma mère adorait dit
Piaf donc j'ai grandi avec un peu de
musique française de Steve jazz c'est
d'ailleurs un style musical que
j'apprécie comme la sole et
l'instrumental cependant j'aime bien
également les nouveaux artistes
d'ailleurs connais-tu ma Peter elle est
compositrice comme moi mais elle a
également créé des bits et beaucoup de
remix de ses chansons elle est vraiment
cool en plus j'ai été hôtesse de l'air
c'est quatre dernières années donc j'ai
des amis dans le monde entier par
exemple j'avais une collègue du Ghana
qui écoutait beaucoup de musique
française
finalement je retrouve de la musique
française de temps à autre et ça me fait
plaisir parce que j'aime énormément
cette langue
ton premier album est sorti en 2013
pourquoi tu n'en as pas sorti d'autres
depuis
je me suis concentré sur la sortie des
singles vous savez j'avais 13 ans quand
l'album est sorti donc j'ai continué à
aller à l'école j'ai passé mon
baccalauréat et ensuite j'ai voulu
connaître le monde d'abord je me suis
dit que c'était la meilleure façon de
savoir ce que je voulais faire dans la
vie c'est pour cela que je suis devenu
hôtesse de l'air à Vienne et que j'ai
parcouru la planète à cette époque je
n'avais pas beaucoup de temps pour faire
de la musique mais elle a été toujours
là et je me suis rendu compte finalement
que c'est ce que je voulais faire
actuellement je fais des études en
production sonore et musicale et je suis
de retour dans l'univers musical
l'année dernière j'ai lancé un EP
intitulé lovich
other et mon nous les uns les autres et
en ce moment je travaille sur un morceau
totalement opposé un morceau intitulé
Paris
l'ensemble de ces chansons formeront un
album qui aura pour nom soit lovic other
soit par riche je crois que l'album
sortira
on verra il faut savoir que je crée et
produit ma musique moi-même j'écris les
chansons tout cela constitue un
processus créatif il est donc difficile
pour moi de vous dire quand est-ce que
je vais lancer un album mais je crois
qu'il sera sorti au printemps 2023 les
chansons sont presque finalisées et je
suis très content et impatiente d'en
dévoiler certaines d'entre elles
quels sont tes projets futurs dans la
musique
je ne suis pas encore sûr de finir par
être productrice musicale
artiste ou éventuellement en combiner
les deux ce qui serait un rêve mais en
ce moment je veux me concentrer sur mes
études pour pouvoir avoir un parcours
technique et avoir la possibilité de
produire de belles chansons
mes études doivent encore durer environ
deux ans et ensuite je me pencherai sur
ma musique et faire juste ce que j'aime
déménager dans des endroits différents
peut-être rencontrer des personnes
sympathiques passer des bons moments et
avec un peu de chance vivre de ma
passion faire de la musique
et pour terminer cette émission nous
allons vous faire découvrir radio Clank
breit la radio jeunesse de la ville
d'achat fenborg son objectifs donner
envie aux jeunes de découvrir l'univers
de la radio un projet né il y a 20 ans
on écoute Martina feldner elle est
députée du parlement régional de Bavière
est né il y a de nombreuses années avec
la Fédération municipale des jeunes
d'achats Facebook ce sont de jeunes
engagés qui se sont dit on a envie de
faire de la radio c'est comme ça que le
projet radio-claude a vu le jour c'était
une coopération entre la ville d'achat
findbourg et le Centre Fédéral bavarois
pour les nouveaux médias ensemble avec
la fédération mais comme je le disais
l'initiative par Télé jeunes qui avaient
très envie de faire de la radio ils sont
très actifs c'est un très beau projet
qui permet aux jeunes de se former à
l'utilisation des médias et de
travailler les compétences clés
notamment en matière de journaliste
je suis maintenant avec Kersten Gunther
bonjour vous êtes là directrice donc
pédagogique de quel est l'objectif
principal de cette radio
l'objectif principal de notre radio est
bien évidemment de faire de la radio
mais derrière cela il apprentissage
autour de l'information au
journalistique notre mission est
également de donner confiance aux jeunes
donc on vise principalement
l'accélération ou l'émergence de la
confiance en soi des jeunes pour qu'il
puisse mieux faire entendre leur voix et
pour pour finir quels sont les
programmes qui sont diffusés quels sont
les différents sujets que vous abordez
via cette radio nous avons deux
émissions une le mardi soir de 19h à 21h
où il n'y a qu'un seul sujet par exemple
ce soir la thématique de l'émission est
tout est une question de déchet le jeudi
soir nous avons une autre émission avec
cette fois tous les types de sujets
confondus c'est donc une émission très
variée elle se déroule de 19h à 20h et à
la fin de celle-ci entre 20h et 21 nous
faisons également une interview avec par
exemple un artiste local ou des
personnes qui ont un profil qui
intéresse mon équipe merci beaucoup
kering d'avoir été avec nous et merci
beaucoup pour pour l'accueil à achat &
burger merci zone Europe c'est terminé
vous pouvez retrouver cette émission en
replay sur notre site Internet ou sur
notre application radio sensation et
nous on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
pour un nouveau numéro bonne soirée à
tous
avec le soutien financier du Fonds
citoyen franco-allemand